the good news is that biden is up to 49
percent in the polls and uh he's killing
it with voters who are frustrated and
barely give a uh i'm not kidding
look at this there's a new there's a new
category of voter they're calling the
meh voter
they're not enthusiastic about either
side look at this among voters who say
they are somewhat disapproval biden 33
point lead
and you know when you're uh on their
list the dnc fundraising list which i am
because i gave a million dollars to
democrats a couple of times so they
obviously i get like eight letters okay
i get like eight letters a day i'm happy
with one of those donations uh but uh so
they're going after the met voter look
at this letter i'm going to read it to
you the one i got would you like to see
the
i thought
this is their latest fundraising letter
uh it says uh william are you mildly
enthused
[Laughter]
william there are times when hope unites
a nation and the promise of a better day
brings out the best in all americans
this is not one of those times
but our democracy is in danger this is
your chance to tell president biden
you've heard of him
[Applause]
and you stand behind him 30 to 40
percent
now more than ever we need joe biden in
washington doing whatever it is he does
we're reaching out to you today because
you haven't donated to the democratic
party this election cycle but we see you
spend 6 50 on a venti soy frappuccino
every morning
can we count on you for a two dollar
donation how about 50 cents
how about you pledge not to give any
money to the other side
be a part of the growing number of
voters who only somewhat disapprove of
what we're doing
there are so many good reasons to give
democrats your vote we could be worse
there's no other option the other guy's
a dick
[Applause]
and william we need your tepid support
to almost make it happen
can we count on your vote if it's not
raining
remember the republicans want to cut
taxes on
billionaires the same billionaires who
refused to release the batgirl movie
donate now and join joe biden and the
democrats and saying i'm meh as hell and
i'm gonna take it anymore
you